dans cette histoire il ya une vieille
peugeot des poupées barbie 110 bars des
montres suisses un ballet breveter un
parages célèbre le peintre dali les
nazis en france une signature qui vaut
de l'or
un mystérieux colonel corse une famille
de 15 enfants à héros méconnus trente
mille vies sauvées et humanisme une
valise verts qui va bouleverser la vie
confortable d'andré l'hôte est
professeur de littérature française à
l'université de montréal spécialiste de
jean giono mère de deux enfants dont un
musicien david
je devais vendre la maison de ma mère
qui était décédé quelques mois
auparavant
un jour ma fille me dit maman 1 quand
ira chez mamie est ce que tu pourrais te
plais regardez c'est tu trouverais pas
de tes anciennes poupée barbie
je suis descendu au sous sol il y avait
une série de valises qui était en public
c'était des grosses valises vous savez
comme on voit dans le film tout à coup
j'en ai trouvé une qui tu es une plus
petite que les autres une valise verte
et quand j'ai pris les petites boucles
argentées qui en fait j'étais surprise
par des centaines de papiers tout
portait le nom de mon père pour moi
c'était un peu comme arrivée dans la
caverne d'ali baba vous savez et trouver
coffre aux trésors
j'ai découvert un premier papier qui
était du consulat de pologne à montréal
qui était datée de 1945 et il y avait
cru dessus ce site une attestation pour
dire que monsieur jacques l'hôte et
tirait jacob l'automne berg est un
citoyen honorable jacob noté mme berg
andré lhôte et avait cinq ans quand son
père est décédé sa mère cécile lambert
ne lui en avait jamais beaucoup parlé
ces souvenirs sont vagues mais
affectueux et surtout enveloppée de
mystère
on m'avait toujours demandé depuis ma
tendre enfance mais vous savez bien
l'hôte et je viens d'où et ma mère
disait toujours c'est un nom polonais
qui a été écourtée parce que ton grand
père était dans les affaires à paris
mais là j'avais la vraie réponse alors
noté mme berg ça ne faisait aucun doute
avec un suffixe comme ça que c'était un
an juif dans cette valise toute une vie
celle de jacob l'automne bègue né en
pologne
fils de diamantaires à anvers en
belgique volontaire à 17 ans dans
l'armée polonaise vers la fin de la
grande guerre
elle savait qu'à montréal son père
importer les montres suisses et nicard
mais elle apprend aussi qu'il avait été
copropriétaire d'une charcuterie
hébraïque aujourd'hui disparu juste à
côté de chez schwarz rue saint laurent à
montréal puis avec les documents dans la
valise
elle remonte le temps j'ai trouvé que en
37 me père avait un commerce à paris et
qui était rue de wagram
c'est une boutique d'accessoires que
tenait son père les nouveautés l'hôte et
il a même breveter une invention un
ballet inusable j'ai découvert aussi que
mon père avait était marié et qu'il
avait une petite fille jacqueline en
cette demi soeur aujourd'hui décédé
andré ne l'a jamais connue elle se lance
dans une vaste enquête ici en europe où
elle établi de nombreux contacts
alors je dis ça va jacky lui fournit une
mine de renseignements c'est une
passionnée d'histoire établi en belgique
elles aident à comprendre une foule de
choses sur la famille d'andré la guerre
éclate en 1939
la pologne est envahie par les nazis
dans la valise verte
andré a trouvé des cartes postales
écrites en allemand à son père en
provenance de pologne ce qui m'a glacé
mais vraiment horrifié c'est que jean
regardant de plus près j'ai vu là ici le
sceau de la gestapo
ces cartes venait de notre anarchy était
la soeur de mon père et donc j'ai
compris qu'elle avait été emprisonné au
ghetto
dans le ghetto de lodz les lettres sont
censurés par l'armée allemande mais on
devine la détresse des prisonniers du
ghetto de lodz
nous remercions dieu nous sommes en
santé mais nous avons l'air terrible
nous te prions de nous envoyer du
poisson de l'huile d'olive ou d'autres
matières grasses et un peu de café et
j'ai découvert qu'elle avait été une des
rares survivantes je crois qu'ils
étaient environ huit cents seulement
elle a été en 44 a été ensuite déporté à
auschwitz après sa fausse engberg et
après ça attire is in stat où elle a été
libérée par l'armée russe mai 1940 les
allemands envahissent la france et il
persécute les juifs
le 18 juin le général de gaulle et à
londres
ils lancent aux français son fameux
appel à la résistance six millions de
français fuient la vence nazis vers le
sud
c'est l'exode lehning pour moi a
toujours été si mon père s'appelle lot
enberg et qu'il habitait paris en 1937
avec sa femme et sa fille comment at il
bien pu s'échapper
il doit s'enfuir de paris ce bout de
papier tout rafistolé était le bien le
plus précieux de jacob l'automne berg
devenu que jacques l'automne berg et il
raconte une véritable odyssée
c'est un papier datée du 18 juin 40
et qui dit que monsieur jacques noté mme
berg chauffeur du colonel aviateurs
giovanoli titulaires du passeport canada
et se rend à paris et à biarritz et
retour en voiture peugeot immatriculée
quatre saisons 9 r am3 le rapport de
jacques l'automne berg avec le colonel
giovanoli un militaire français
d'origine corse décoré de la légion
d'honneur reste nébuleux c'était il
rencontrait dans l'armée 20 ans plus tôt
et que faisait un commerçant parisiens
chauffeur d'un militaire c'est une
grande énigme pour moi encore est-ce
qu'ils étaient ensemble mais ce qui
n'était pas ensemble dans la peugeot je
ne sais pas jacques l'automne berg est
parmi les derniers à franchir la
frontière espagnole près d'hendaye le 25
juin 1940 au volant de la peugeot avec
son précieux sauf conduit enfin libre il
traverse l'espagne se réfugier au
portugal sa femme b sita et sa fille
jacqueline parviennent à s'embarquer
pour le brésil lui est refusée il
restera un an et demi au portugal on
peut juste imaginer le drame des d'un
père d'une famille comme ça ça paraît
c'est ça d'être épouvantables dans le
coin du fameux document un visa pour le
portugal
andré parvient à identifier l'auteur de
la signature une signature qui vaut de
l'or
quand j'ai tapé toutes ces dates tout
m'a dirigé vers à rester de sousa mendes
qui était le consul
du portugal à bordeaux en 1939
andré découvre ainsi l'existence d'un
personnage plus grand que nature dont
l'histoire
valve a bouleversé c'est un choc pour
moi c'est un peu comme se retrouver sur
la liste de schindler
ces recherches ont conduit andré sur les
traces de la grande famille d'aristides
de sousa mendes jusque chez ruth 88 ans
la veuve de l'un des fils du consul luis
felipe et deux de leurs trois enfants
louis philippe et linda ils vivent à
montréal
senah mango ensemble ils revivent la
grande saga du consul de bordeaux
aristide et son jumeau césar grandi dans
une famille aristocratique du portugal
leur père est un juge respecté les deux
frères feront une belle carrière dans la
diplomatie
son épouse angelina à ses côtés aristide
est nommé consul en guyane britannique à
zanzibar au brésil à anvers en belgique
en 1938 le président antonio salazar le
nomme à bordeaux il s'y installe avec
ses 14 enfants
lorsque la guerre éclate césar et
ambassadeur du portugal
à varsovie il sait tout des persécutions
des nazis en pologne en particulier des
juifs et il en informe son frère les
réfugiés affluent à la frontière
espagnole
le consul leur aimé des visas portugais
qui leur permettront de traverser
l'espagne
quand ces gens-là ville au portugal il
correspondait bon est-ce que l'autorité
exigeait s'est par la suite qu'elle
salazar a émis la circulaire 14 qui
interdisent absolument qu'ils donnent
des visas le doute l'assaille
doit-il obéir comme tout le monde sa
rencontre avec le rabbin chaïm krueger
lui ouvre les yeux
le film désobéir relate cet épisode ne
partent pas
quitter la france pas tout seul mon cher
qu'on suit je ne peux pas partir tout
seul on est en lien ici
le rabbin refus son visa s'il ne peut
amener tous les réfugiés qui sont avec
lui après trois jours de réclusion total
aristide en ressort les cheveux tous
blanchis et ça fait le serment de
délivrer des visas à tous ceux qui
veulent vendre des milliers de visas
émis vers le portugal et la liberté
amy jour et nuit en désobéissance total
des ordres du dictateur salazar
sympathisants des nazis il y avait son
devoir en grande autorité mais a changé
l'autorité la figure d'autorité et il
changeait saint lazare pour sa foi
aristides de sousa mendes aura donné la
liberté des milliers de gens ordinaires
mais aussi à plusieurs membres de la
famille rothschild au peintre salvador
dali à l'archiduc héritiers d'autriche
otto de habsbourg et sa famille à la
duchesse de luxembourg et à sa famille
les envoyés de saint lazare sont aux
trousses du consul qui continuent à
désobéir à l'oser il prend la tête
personnellement d'un dernier petit
groupe jusqu'à la frontière
les espagnols ferme la porte aux
réfugiés porteur d'un visa interdit
celui de sousa mendes
ils passeront par un petit post qui
n'avait pas le téléphone et ignorait la
consigne on croit que jacques l'automne
berg et sa famille étaient du nombre
avec sa fameuse liste oskar schindler a
sauvé plus d'un millier de juifs mais en
neuf jours seulement de sousa mendes a
sauvé environ trente mille personnes
dont un tiers de juifs
moi c'est ce que j'admire le plus c'est
le courage dont il ne fait pas avec son
épouse angelina au delà de tout ils ont
décidé prendre de risque de droit et
honnête il paiera le prix fort pour sa
désobéissance rappeler à lisbonne consul
sera jugé et rayé de la carrière
diplomatique privé des trois quarts de
ses revenus pour que ces enfants
échappent à leur situation de paria dans
leur propre pays
il les enverra tous à l'étranger il
mourra dans un grand dénuement
en 1954 six ans après sa femme angelina
et puis pouvais plus aller à l'école
n'avait plus les moyens d'aller à
l'école les autorités de toute façon
donc c'est son père qui lui a enseigné
les mathématiques l'histoire la
géographie
aristide cherche à faire instruire luis
felipe son plus jeune fils hors du
portugal
une invitation providentiel arrive de
québec
quand il était consul en belgique
arrested ouvrait sa maison tous les
dimanches aux étudiants étrangers
parmi ceux ci un jeune prêtre prénommé
alphonse marie le futur monseigneur
parents recteur de l'université laval
c'est lui qui accueillera en 1948 luis
felipe qui deviendra ingénieurs
au québec luis felipe n'a qu'une envie
tout oublié il épouse ruth tremblay et
fonde une famille c'est trop il y avait
peur de s'endetter et l'ia c'est un
cauchemar
il n'y avait pas il y avait une douleur
très profonde qu'il avait dans son cas
son remède sa façon de faire c'est de
fonder une famille et puis ensuite de
travailler d'être passionné pour son
travail
et puis quand j'ai arrêté de travailler
une tristesse qui faisait surface
luis felipe participe à la construction
du barrage daniel-johnson à la manic il
sent qu'il prend racine là où on veut
lui il a bien réussi et les devenu un
expert international en barrages mais
comme tous ses frères et soeurs il lui
restait un devoir à accomplir le devoir
de mémoire
une fois que cette histoire est connue
et reconnue n'appartiendrait pu à la
famille puis ce serait la libération
pour la famille puis elle appartiendrait
à l'humanité des fondations de sousa
mendes ont été créés c'est avec des gens
commanderait que la famille sousa mendes
dispersés à travers le monde a pu
reconstituer la saga du consul de
bordeaux et réhabiliter la mémoire d'un
héros oubliés de l'humanité et shoegaze
des hommages ont été rendus à travers le
monde
il a été inscrit sur la liste des justes
parmi les nations
au mémorial de l'holocauste de yad
vashem à jérusalem
son nom figure sur des plaques
commémoratives dans de nombreux pays
ce parc de montréal lui était dédié
l'état portugais s'est officiellement
excusé auprès de la famille et à
restituer
trente ans après sa mort tous les titres
et les droits qu'il avait retiré
aristides de sousa mendes
on veut maintenant restaurer le vieux
manoir familial au portugal et en faire
un musée
enfin la sorte qu'un jour la justice
soit faite et que leurs noms soient
soient reconnus comme comme éteint
celui d'une personne qui fait la bonne
chose au bon moment quelques jours avant
de mourir
mon grand père indien 19h10 gériez vous
laisser mais que mon nom mais il est
propre
c'est un très bel exemple pour tous les
jeunes filles puis on dit fois à
désobéir pour ne pas les contrôleurs
conscience
seulement 3000 personnes sur les 30
mille qui ont été sauvés par sousa
mendes sont connus beaucoup de familles
ignorent encore toute cette histoire
ou bien elles ont décidé comme la mer
d'andré de taire leurs secrets
quand mon père est décédé et que je
n'avais que cinq ans elle a estimé qu'il
y avait déjà probablement à ces deux
drames comme ça dans ma vie
alors elle a laissé le soin au destin de
décider quand je trouverais la vérité